et en europe manifestation à rome en
italie cet après midi quelques centaines
de personnes venues dire non à la guerre
et témoigner de leur solidarité avec le
peuple ukrainien
il est là pour la mobilisation du pays
qui se mobilisent pour aider kiev et les
soutiens qu'ils s'organisent
manifestations également en france dans
plusieurs villes à rennes à cannes à
tours dijon lorient ou encore marseille
eux aussi venus dire non à la guerre on
retrouve place de la république à paris
raphaël glucksmann essayiste directeur
du nouveau magazine littéraire et député
européen bonjour vous protester contre
l'invasion russe trouvez vous que
l'europe en fasse assez dans le soutien
aux ukrainiens
bonjour non n'en fera jamais assez dans
le soutien à la résistance du peuple
ukrainien est aujourd'hui ce qu'on est
venu demander sur cette place d'abord
c'est exprimer notre solidarité avec
cette résistance qui fait face à une
invasion absolument horrible effet aussi
de demander aux dirigeants européens
d'être encore plus cohérent et encore
plus fermes dans leur politique de
sanctions à l'égard du régime de
vladimir poutine il y a encore des trous
dans la raquette de ces sanctions et il
est vraiment vraiment important que le
message qui est envoyé à moscou soit un
message d'une fermeté absolue
par exemple nous demandons l'exclusion
de toutes les banques russes du système
bancaire international swift nous
demandons aussi que si les dirigeants de
l'otan et de l'union européenne ne sont
pas capables et bien de faire en sorte
de fermer le ciel ukrainien aux avions
russes eh bien ils fournissent à la
résistance ukrainienne les moyens de le
faire elle même et donc il y a encore
fait
[Musique]
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut un
engagement militaire de l'europe
on ne peut pas faire la guerre à la
russie c'est une évidence les pays de
l'otan et de l'union européenne ne
feront pas légal a réussi par contre les
ukrainiens les ukrainiennes qui eux
n'ont pas le choix et qu'ils doivent la
faire parce que l'armée russe et sur
leur terre et menace de raser leurs
villes et leurs villages eh bien nous
devons les aider encore plus que nous le
faisons aujourd'hui et on ne pourra pas
avoir un engagement militaire directe
mais nous pouvons encore faire beaucoup
plus que ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
pour permettre à la résistance sucré
nien de repousser l'envahisseur russe
est aussi aussi pour permettre et bien
de frapper plus fort encore le régime de
vladimir poutine êtes vous pour la
constitution de brigades internationales
comme l'a demandé le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky
ça ça peut être la position demeure du
président en haleine ce qui est si les
gens veulent s'engager c'est tout à leur
honneur et là la position des dirigeants
européens
moi je suis député européen la position
des dirigeants aucun c'est de faire tout
ce qui est en leur pouvoir à l'exception
d'une guerre directe pour frapper fort
le régime de vladimir poutine et donc il
faut se focaliser sur les sanctions et
sur le soutien en termes d'équipement à
la résistance ukrainienne et je dois
dire que c'est pas encore ancré dans
toutes les têtes en europe mais si nous
n'arrêtons pas boutines en ukraine eh
bien nous ne connaîtrons plus la paix
sur le continent européen et donc il va
falloir passer à une étape supérieure
des sanctions y compris sur le gaz et
sur le pétrole ça aura un prix pour les
occidentaux sera un prix pour les
européens mais en réalité le prix de
l'inaction le prix du laissez faire est
infiniment plus grand que le prix des
sanctions qu'on peut prendre aujourd'hui
est ce que vous êtes pour l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'otan comme l'a demandé il
ya encore deux semaines volodymyr
zelensky et pour l'adhésion rapide de
l'ukraine dans l'europe bien qu'elles ne
répondent elles ne répondent pas aux
conditions requises
actuellement
ce qui se discute aujourd'hui à
bruxelles c'est le l'octroi du statut de
pays candidat à l'ue à l'union
européenne pour l'ukraine et et bien sûr
que je suis pour l'octroi de ce statut
de pays candidat ou sa initierez un long
processus l'ukraine n'est pas prête à
rentrer dans l'union européenne
aujourd'hui mais c'est le moment au
moment où on se parle là d'envoyer un
message symboliquement extrêmement forte
et extrêmement clair oui l'ukraine
appartient à la famille des démocraties
européennes
eh oui l'ukraine vivra libre dans la
famille des nations européennes libre et
donc le destin de l'ukraine et bien
c'est d'intégrer l'union européenne mais
ça se fera pas en deux semaines et ça
les autorités ukrainiennes le savent
pertinemment ce qu'ils veulent ce
qu'elles demandent les autorités
ukrainiennes c'est que l'union
européenne envoie un signal extrêmement
clair sur le caractère irréversible du
destin européen de l'ukraine
merci beaucoup raphaël glucksmann
d'avoir été avec nous sur facebook merci